Speaker 1: Hurricane Ian may be making landfall in
Florida quite literally as we speak. I hope every
one of our viewers in the areas that are getting
hit and we have a lot of viewers in those areas
are heeding the precautions, evacuating. If you've
been indicated that if it's been indicated that
you should evacuate. Fox News propagandist Tucker
Carlson is saying that hurricanes are a scam.
We are going to take a look at a clip of Tucker's
show from last night. Let's take a listen.
So you hate to hype hurricanes because it's just
a staple of TV and everyone's kind of on to the
scam. But there's a legitimately large hurricane
barreling toward the Gulf Coast of Florida
tonight. Hurricane bigger than we've seen in more
than 100 years, the foremost hurricane predictor
in this country. Many people vie for the title.
But this man may take it. Joins us after the
break. Yeah. So, listen, I I don't know whether
Tucker is saying that worrying about hurricanes
is generally a scam or that the media coverage
of the hurricane industrial complex is a scam.
But it is genuinely scary that Fox News's business
model in many ways is tell our viewers that they
are being lied to about lots of different things
that will actually keep them safer. Right. Don't
get the vaccine. Don't take precautions on COVID.
There is no climate change. Hurricanes are a scam.
Now, the most charitable interpretation of what
Tucker Carlson is saying here is the way that
media outlets spend days covering hurricanes,
sending reporters to stand in the wind and the
rain and the entire thing, the disaster porn
videos, that that is a scam. That would be the
most charitable interpretation of what Tucker is
saying. And if that's the case, his own network is
one of the greatest perpetrators of that very
scam, because Fox News does it all the time.
They will do the 24 seven hurricane coverage just
like everybody else. So it's never really clear
what Tucker Carlson is saying. And this is kind
of part of his game to always use sort of coded
language or to kind of dance around issues
in some way. It's not exactly clear what he
means that the scam is, but the theme here is Fox
News participates in whatever scam he's talking
about just as much as everybody else. And if
you exclusively get your news from Fox News,
you are more likely to be receiving suggestions,
implicit or explicit, that you engage in behavior
that is quite literally putting your life at risk
and that is wacky. We will have all of these clips
on our Instagram. Make sure you're following
us at David Pakman show. We will take a quick
break and be back to cover the growing Republican
civil war as we get closer to 2024. Stay with me.